bajo estos edificios de hormigón en el
medio de las montañas suiza cultiva su
particularidad aquí una ley del inicio
de los años
1960 hace obligatorio la construcción de
refugios de concreto el principio 1 por
cada habitante javi todo aguas a plazas
cada habitante debe tener su lugar
protegido entonces bajo cada edificio de
este distrito hay refugios privados para
las escuelas también hay refugios
públicos de más de 300 lugares realmente
son destinados a proteger a la población
local a la población local por hipótesis
dentro todo está previsto para vivir de
manera cómoda se encuentran camas duchas
salas de mando e incluso hospitales todo
para sobrevivir en caso de conflicto
olvidadas estos últimos años y hasta
amenazadas por el poder legislativo la
guerra de ucrania despertó el interés de
los habitantes por estas construcciones
poco nos damos cuenta que hay centrales
nucleares en suiza hay centrales en
europa en varios lugares entonces si es
útil fue construido para eso y creo que
hoy tenemos que conservarlos
acaso con lo que está ocurriendo hoy
tenemos que conservarlos y tenerlos
preparados
el país cuenta con 365 mil refugios
privados y públicos que pueden acoger
hasta 9 millones de personas sin embargo
las diferencias regionales subsisten
genera por ejemplo está particularmente
poco votada con una tasa de cobertura de
alrededor del 75 por ciento